[music]
[music] [music] [
music]
[music] Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to all of you.
On this auspicious day, family and friends gather together to
wish our dear and precious birthday.  Let me congratulate you.
Let me introduce myself first.
[music]
You've finally come.
]
Ladies and gentlemen, we are waiting for an important lady to board. Please
welcome us with a big round of applause.
Thank you for your participation.
[Music] Let's be
thrilled together next time at that place
[Applause]
[Music]
This place is finally settled How are you?  Keep it in your
hands Press your quibbles on us and tie us up I'll get rid of you
today
Give me back Do
n't think it's easy to meet You
fools who were lured out
Everyone are arrested now
[Music]
[Music] I managed to
hide it.  The
sea boss is still on the run, but it doesn't matter if the
quest is completed for the time being Cass
's true identity has been revealed The
fake Nyanko Sea already exists, and I think
Fuu is
safe.  But you don't have to open it Please
sleep well I have work tomorrow too
[music] [music] [music] [
music]
[music]